rocket this has been described as one
last ride so is this your final time
playing Rocket Raccoon do you think I I
go wherever James sells me
so elegant and perfect right now with
the three films it's incredible and so
to think of moving forward it's really
hard and without James I don't like I
don't know I don't know
that franchise changed my life not just
my career but it changed my life so it's
hard letting go at the same time it's
been 10 years and I still have places I
want to go as a performer so I I have to
let go James Gunn has already announced
it his it's his last film and when James
is done I'm done I want the Guardians to
continue myself like that doesn't
necessarily mean with Chris or with
anybody but you know I I would like to
see you know the Guardians continue in
another another iteration